[موسيقى]
على الرغم من أنني لؤلؤة ، لا تقطع هذا السلك
غير مسموح
[موسيقى]
واحدة من هذه الجروح هي قضية الحجاب.
لقد ارتكبنا أخطاء هنا أيضًا.
في الماضي لكننا عرفنا كيف نتعلم التغيير
حان الوقت الآن لاتخاذ الخطوة التالية
لا تتخطى هذه القضية كمجتمع.
حان وقت الإقلاع عن التدخين
[موسيقى]
أنت الآن ترتدي بعض الحجاب
نخدع أخينا بطريقة أو بأخرى
انت تأخذ
يمكنك التقاط الصور معهم و
لخداع هذه الأمة معهم.
انت تحاول
نفس Kılıçdaroğlu
من المدارس إلى المؤسسات العامة.
على الأرض
الحق في الحجاب لفتياتنا و
كل ما نقوم به لنمنح نسائنا
ضد اللوائح
[موسيقى]
في تركيا
لملابس النساء والحجاب
لا أحد يتدخل في حياتهم الخاصة
لكن هذه ليست حياة أحد الخاصة
إنه ليس مكانًا
هذه هي أعلى مؤسسة للدولة.
[موسيقى]